we're gonna leave you with chris evans
who had the time of his life playing
with puppies in what has to be the
cutest interview ever i know i love this
chris took part in the buzzfeed's puppy
interview and could barely get through
the questions as he was
way too distracted by his furry friends
and i don't blame him for it take a look
take care everybody we'll see you
tomorrow bye bye
guys this is the best interview
hi guys hi
hi hi boobie hi
hi
oh my god you guys are so sweet
it had to happen
who cares
uh if i can play any marvel video what
should i pick what should i pick maybe
uh loki seems to have the most fun come
here guys come here
come here come over here come here hi hi
hi buster
look at you guys guys
good luck come get it
go get it
oh man
this is terrible
oh bubby hey pal my dog dodger i i
rescued him and he was though a puppy
technically he was probably two years
old at the time i always thought when i
adopted a dog or rescued a dog it would
be a little puppy and dodger was a
full-grown dog and it wasn't the story i
had in my mind but it ended up being the
best decision of my life so i just think
a lot of
adult dogs and
older dogs get overlooked and that's a
shame so let's give them some love too
excuse you
what a good man